[Musique]
la surprise c'est bien elle sandrine
rousseau qualifié pour le second tour
des primaires écologistes est une
victoire d'être au second tour c'est une
victoire d'être si proche parent d'être
dans un mouchoir de poche avec yannick
jadot et je vous promet d'autres
surprises dit qu'elle veut tout changer
dans la décroît les
féministes radicalité avec d'ailleurs
des questions qui se posent sur son
relation valeurs républicaines au
communautarisme des propositions à dire
choc revenu d'existence lui 150 euros
manche et pour les plus de 18 ans la
taxe carbone pour les entreprises la
production d'énergie donc je me sens %
renouvelable d'ici à 2050 je trouvais
que yannick jadot était de loin la
personnalité qui pouvait le mieux
représenter l'écologie dans une
élection présidentielle et donc il n'a
pas plié le match et je te crois qu'il
est en ballottage défavorable
les verts ne sont toujours pas pris et
clairement à gouverner avec avec des
scores d'ailleurs qui sont très serrés
et qui montrent qu'ils n'ont pas de
leader naturel je serai là surprise de
cette présidentielle et j'irai jusqu'au
bout jusqu'en avril 2022 donc si vous
serez sûr du résultat entre nous
franchement vous préférer une
candidature jadot non
je préfère une candidature écolo et sans
langue de bois je vous répondrai en
octobre jadot ça vous rassure peuple
jusqu'au ruisseau pour rassembler la
gauche je vous dirai pas mon vote
yannick jadot n'a pas la dynamique qu'il
pensait avoir et puis un score très fort
de de sandrine rousseau qui qui est
quand même très courues ce qu'un peu
déconnectés de la réalité
barbara seront punis a saboté toutes les
politiques écologistes qu'elle avait
amené durant ce mandat que la loi climat
n'est pas du tout à la à la hauteur des
enjeux avec son positionnement politique
dans cette primaire elle pourra jamais
gagner une présidentielle ni l'inde et
d'autres la crise des sous-marins et
londres qui cajole paris après l'annoncé
narnia stratégique entre les états unis
l'australie et le royaume uni selon le
premier ministre boris johnson la
relation entre la france et le royaume
uni et je cite indéracinable nous
n'avons absolument pas été informé du
nouveau cours choisis par l'australie
mais en plus il ya eu un nouveau coup de
chapeau aux contrats que nous avions
signé en 2016 entre l'australie et la
france la france ne savais pas a affirmé
les deux hommes pourtant en février
dernier à la télé australienne on
pouvait déjà sentir le vent tourner le
premier ministre est de plus en plus
inquiets et depuis le mois d'octobre aux
fonctionnaires dirige un groupe de
travail pour examiner tous les aspects
du contrat des sous marins sont de
possibles alternatives au nom de la
france je dis aux harkis et à leurs
enfants à voix haute et solennelle
que la république a alors contracté à
leur égard une dette il attendait autre
chose qu'un discours 300 harkis ces
anciens combattant aux côtés de l'armée
française pendant la guerre d'algérie
réclamait une loi de reconnaissance de
leur abandon après leur avoir demandé
pardon aux combattants abandonnés à leur
famille qu'ils ont subi les camps la
prison le déni
se demande pardon
[Musique]
parmi ceux qui n'ont pas eu accès
privilégié il ya envoyé spécial qui a le
malheur de s'intéresser de trop près aux
chiffres de vente du livre
pour vaincre
pour mieux agir
[Musique]
il en candidate aux safa kapango l'eau
non république à nantes et menace
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
your time et sap
[Musique]
maintenant je peux voir
car minable